the space shuttle Challenger disaster
could be traced to one mistake the
failure of these black rubber bands they
were meant to seal the right solid
rocket booster joint the O-rings as
they're called were supposed to move
into the groove to prevent the hot gases
from leaking but the cold weather caused
both the primary and back of o-ring to
stiffen so they failed to stop the gas
from escaping as proof scientist Richard
Feynman dunked a rubber o-ring into a
glass of ice water it doesn't stretch
back it stays the same Dimension I
believe that has some significance
for our problem this discovery put
Feynman on the map for the full video on
his incredible life the link is in my
comments